[Music]
Asylum Seekers from Ameritrade could
face being deported from Israel
following running battles on the streets
of Tel Aviv the Israeli government will
meet to discuss how to respond to
Saturday's violence in which 170 people
were injured the fighting was between
exiled opponents and supporters of the
Eritrean government Paul Brennan is live
for us in Western Jerusalem so Paul
first up was this so unexpected do you
think
well we certainly knew about the tension
between the two elements of the Eritrean
Community here in Israel and the police
say that they had given permission for
two separate protests or two separate
events to take place with the promise
from both sides that they would stay
separate but I think perhaps in
hindsight it was entirely predictable
that violence would ensue and what we
saw in the end were unprecedented scenes
the airspitting banks of stun grenades
and the accurate smell of tear gas in
Tel Aviv
as rival groups from Israel's Eritrean
Community engaged in pitched battles
with rocks and clubs local people
described it as being like a war zone
the Catalyst for the violence an event
organized by the Eritrean Embassy to
celebrate the government of President
Isaiah's of working and 30 years of
Eritrean Independence but eritreans who
have fled the country because of
Africa's authoritarian rule are outraged
why did we run from our country because
of this dictator why they are
celebrating here today why did the
Israel police give them a permit to
celebrate for this dictator we are
against this why am I here seeking
Asylum
what is happening here is that dictator
wants to do a festival we are against
this Festival we are not living a good
life he is creating chaos and problems
for us we are against him we don't want
a festival to take place here the result
was Fury and Chaos police say they'd
consulted both sides in the Eritrean
community in recent days and were not
expecting this intensity of violence
that assessment now looks seriously
questionable
casualties were taken to several
different medical centers among the
wounded several described as seriously
hurt and some critically ill dozens of
police officers were also injured
there's been political reaction to
members of Israel's right-wing coalition
government blaming the high court for
what they said were decisions which
facilitated the violence opposition
members of the knesset rapidly pointing
the finger of blame back at the
government the demonstrators were
finally dispersed after several hours
leaving behind blood-stained Pavements
and smashed up shop windows and a sense
of simmering tension
whole Brennan Al Jazeera occupied East
Jerusalem
the thing is Paul the tensions you're
talking about there are long running but
also long ignored
indeed I mean the population uh the
Eritrean population here in Israel is is
around 20 000 that's 0.2 percent of the
population but their plight has been
well known about and has been frankly
brushed under the carpet by successive
governments not just this current
government uh they have a a status
within Society an official status of
conditional release which grants them
really only basic uh rights basic civil
rights but the political Fallout from
this particular incident in Tel Aviv on
Saturday has been to increase the
polarization within Israeli politics
we've had prime minister Netanyahu
coming out uh on Saturday night issuing
a statement saying the following he's
got he and the ministerial team are
going to look into the possibility of
taking action including deportation now
that's not quite that's stopping short
of outright deportation it's a we're
going to look at the options uh but from
both sides of the Divide we've got the
Finance Minister smart trips saying the
high court is responsible for these
riots culture Minister Zohar the
perpetrators must be punished severely
and deported immediately on the other
side opposition politicians blaming the
government and government in action for
the violence opposition leader yeah
lapid this government promised to handle
immigration the immigration crisis and
instead chaos Reigns and Benny gants of
the national Unity party failure the
failure of the current government and we
need to formulate a long-term policy so
you can see it's essentially a an
extension of the kind of polarized I
hesitate to call it culture wars that we
have here in Israel at the moment with
the eritreans and their plight because
so few of them are granted Asylum status
they're regarded as illegal infiltrators
is how even the government describes
them very very marginalized and and
frankly caught in the middle
all right Paul thanks for that Paul
Brennan there reporting from West
Jerusalem